so i'm reading a book no rules rules
which is a story of netflix reed
hastings is talking about how netflix is
with this co-author
just a ridiculous book i highly
recommend and there's a part in this
book
where reid tells a story when one of
their
supervisors one of their leaders ted
sarandis who is now the co-ceo of
netflix as of july of 2020 i believe
he at that time comes to read with a
show they picked
with sandra bullock being in it is
called i believe bird box right
and so they're all like okay i don't
know how bird box is going to do
breed doesn't know but ted is the one
that was responsible for picking
that this is what we're going to do and
we're going to make the investment for
something called
bird box and we're hoping this is going
to do great and rita's like i'm kind of
indifferent about it well long story
short bird box comes out
and it doesn't do well they don't get 5
million of their subscribers watching
this
not 10 million not 20 million 45 million
in the
first week of all netflix subscribers
watch the whole thing 80 million within
four weeks
becomes a massive hit and they get a
bunch of new subscribers
because people want to watch this show
called bird box right
so there's a scene where reed goes up to
ted
to tell ted congratulations ted says on
what
he said i want to congratulate you for
picking bird box
and test like oh cool thanks he says
well congratulations to you as well
he says congratulations to me for what
he said for picking me
he said i don't understand what do you
mean picking me he said you had a lot of
other people
to hire but you picked me and also i
picked
jackie and jackie picked xyz
and through them is how we found bird
box so guess what reed he says what
we all picked well and he sat there reed
saying how interesting in
is this that in life everything's about
picking the right
everything picking the right opportunity
picking the right person you hire being
a great ceo isn't about how smart and
brilliant you are
is you're picking the right people
around you you're picking the right
technology
you're picking the right time to invest
you're picking the right time to go
raise capital
you're picking the right time one to
expand you're picking the right
estates to go into you're picking the
right countries to expanding
everything is about picking and if you
pick accordingly
like if you look at you right now
wherever i was at 25 years old
is because of what i picked i picked my
friends at that time
i picked the businesses at that time i
picked the investments at that time
everything with my life where i was at
20 to 23 years old was based on my
choices and who i picked
as a life advance i made better choices
so if you're watching this right now
saying well pat how does this apply to
me
every aspect of your life who'd you pick
as a spouse who'd you pick as a
boyfriend girlfriend
who'd you pick as a running mate what
did you pick as an industry
what company did you pick to want to be
a part of who's are you who are you
reporting to
what boss did you pick everything there
is about picking
the better you pick and the better a
company does it's a byproduct of a lot
of good picks
just like in draft when you go into you
know the nba draft is going on last week
when you look at the nba draft it's who
you pick there's a lot of flops in the
history of the nba
a lot of them there are a lot of flops
the biggest flop of all time is the one
name everybody talks about
is sam bowie the portland trailblazers
in 1984 with their second picture of sam
bowie you know who the third pick was
michael jordan can you imagine being the
portland trailblazers
for picking sam bui and sambui for the
rest of his life has to be known as the
guy one ahead of who michael jordan
chicago ended up becoming the team
because the owners picked jordan
trailblazers didn't win championships
because they didn't pick up elijah one
or jordan fyi between elijah and jordan
elijah won two championships
jordan won six championships sam bowie
didn't win any championships
just think about everything that like
being picking so as you're watching this
video
and you're going about your week start
asking questions on how you can get
better
on making better picks in every aspect
of your life
and if you make better picks watch how
quickly
your life will expand having said that
if you're watching this video this is a
mindset about being strategic
made a video about art of war and
strategic thinking in 2020 for
entrepreneurs
if you've not watched this video it's
purely about strategy click over here to
watch the video
and moving forward come up with a
strategy to make better picks
so 2021 becomes the beginning of the
greatest years
of your life take care everybody bye-bye